I write everybody so here is another trading model that you guys can use and the thing is I want to
you know I like to keep things simple. I do not want strategies where you have to use
so many things and combine them together and you know use all of those different steps standard
deviation and all even though they might have a better accuracy but overall in the long run if
you stick to simple things that's gonna make you profitable all right so just as I thought to
you about the inverse probability gap so we can do the same with the autoblocks so here you can see
that we get a market structure shift so now you're gonna have an autoblock here consecutive bullish
candles or consecutive up closed candles and you might have noticed that most of the time and
I'm not saying go and watch your charts it's gonna go to the autoblock but it's gonna rip through it
like guys there's a way to to take a trade from here so most of the time the reason why I hate
I'm not saying I hate but I dislike the ICT 2022 model because once you get a market structure
shift and you have like your autoblock here or your favorite gap it's gonna rip through it
most of the time so here's how to trade it you have your autoblock right if it if it goes above it
right and first off it has to go up right wake above it or something like that or close above it
and then I want the body to close below the autoblock a reclaim of autoblock just like inverse
probability gaps and then the entry on the retest and we target somewhere around here
very simple right and if I remove the drawings right here you will get another type of this where
you have a break of structure right and most of the SMZ or ICT traders will try to go along from
the autoblock that should be here consecutive bearish candle or consecutive down closed candles
now you might have noticed that price will not react from here now in most cases in some cases
actually not most yes it can but we have to look for a confirmation entry like that okay but
what if price does this there's a way to enter through it just like ABCD right
you wait for price to sweep the autobock I call it the autoblock liquidity right this low here
wait for a reclaim entry on the retest and you target this very simple this is basically if
you use these simple things because the thing is guys ICT has of course created a lot of smart
money students okay he has like taught so many things and they work they work perfectly but
they didn't work straight away you know each of us every guru out there who is like a gentleman
guru had to go and back test for several months and years it wasn't like a piece of cake where
ICT gave you a strategy and you went on to the charts and then it started to work out of nowhere
we had to test and refine things and when we saw these things working that's when we put it out
on youtube or in the courses so over here this is what works usually you would try to go long here
but what happens we get a sweep a reclaim then an entry on the retest and we target this or
fairly gap around here let me give you guys some examples and then I'll end the video